[MUSIC PLAYING]
IDO GREEN: Hi.
Welcome to our new
series of videos
that will bring you news and
best practices about Actions
on Google.
I'm Ido Green, a developer
advocate for Actions on Google.
I love to help
entrepreneurs and developers
to be more productive.
In this video, I'm
going to show you
how to build an app for
the Google Assistant.
Cool?
Apps for Google Assistants
are a gateway for your users
to engage with your services
through Google Home, Android
phones, iPhones,
and in the future,
through every experience
where the Google Assistant is
available.
It's a new, efficient way
to interact with your users.
Google has been invested
heavily in the areas
of machine learning and speech
recognition and language
understanding.
Google Assistant
brings it all together.
It allows users to have a
conversation with Google
and be more productive.
With Actions on Google, you
could use our investments
in this space, and
your users will
enjoy these new capabilities.
Now, let's build our first
app in less than 15 minutes.
Ready?
The users need to invoke your
app with a phrase like, "OK,
Google.
Let's talk to AnimalJoker."
Now, Google knows
the name of the app
that users choose to use.
The user is now
talking to your app.
Your app generates
dialogue output, which
is then spoken to the user.
The user then make
request, your app
process it, and replies back.
The user has two-way dialogue
until the conversation finish.
For our examples, we
are going to use API.AI.
API.AI use the machine learning
to understand what the user is
trying to tell our app.
Believe me, they are
saving us a lot of work.
You can then respond
to the user's request
from within API.AI, or send
information on the user's
intent to your own
servers to perform
any required action
for fulfillment
and respond to the user.
After the log-in, you
can create your first app
for Google Assistant.
You will need to
give your app a name.
In our case, it
will be AnimalJoker.
Please note that the app name
cannot contain any spaces
between the words.
Click on Save.
It's the button on the top
right corner of the screen.
What are entities?
Entities are the
values that we are
trying to capture
from the user phrases,
kind of like filling out
a form, requesting details
from the user.
API.AI looks to
extract these out,
and will do a follow-up
prompt until completed.
This is how entities
look in API.AI.
We will create an Animal entity.
First step is to click
on Create Entity button.
It's on the top right corner.
Next, you should start
typing animal's name.
The final results should
look similar to the image
on the right.
Please remember, you
should help API.AI machine
learning algorithms train
self by providing synonyms.
For example, a dog
could be also a puppy.
In our case, you could give
it only two, three animals.
That would be fine
for our prototype.
In the real world, try
to give many examples,
so it will cover more cases.
What is an intent?
An intent is triggered by a
series of user says phrases.
This could be something like,
"Please tell me a tiger jokes."
You need to specify
enough sentences
to train API.AI machine
learning algorithms.
Then, even if the
user doesn't say
exactly the words
you typed, API.AI
could still understand them.
You should create
separate intents
for different types of action.
Don't try to combine
them all together.
In our example, we'll
create two intents--
Tell Joke intent, this
intent will handle
the jokes, and a Quit intent.
This intent will handle
the part where the users
wishes to finish the action.
Let's build the
Tell Joke intent.
It's time to create the intent
that will tell us the jokes.
First, click on the
Create Intent button.
Second, start typing
a few sentences
that you will want
to use to get a joke.
For example, "Please
tell me a joke on dogs."
Type a few sentences
so API.AI could
start training its algorithms.
You could see that
while you type,
API.AI automatically
recognize the phrases includes
one of the entities
and highlights it.
See how it looks like.
In the Actions
section, we'll need
to make sure that our
Animal entity is required,
and in the Promote Input
line, we should type, "Please
tell me which animal you like."
This will cover the cases where
the user didn't name an animal.
It will be clear to her
that we need this entity.
Finally, in the Text
Response section,
we will fill our
most amazing jokes.
You could take few ideas
from the image below.
Please note that we are
using the Animal value
in our response
in order to create
a joke that is based on the
animal that the users ask.
After you fill
your amazing jokes,
don't forget to click on Save.
Let's build our Quit intent.
A good design principle
is to allow our users
to end the conversation.
You will need to have
it anyway in order
to pass the review process.
You should click again
on Create Intent button,
then start typing few sentences
that will end the conversation.
For example, "Bye-bye,"
or "Bye, AnimalJoker."
On the right, you could see
how the intent look like.
Last but not least, you need
to check the End Conversation
check box so that it
will know to really end
the conversation at this point.
We are almost done.
It's testing time.
Click on the Integration
on the right-side menu.
This will open the API.AI
agent page with all the options
to integrate it
with our services.
You could see here the
many options that we have.
Click on Action on
Google box under
the one-click integration.
This will enable you to test
your work on Google Home,
a phone, or our web simulator.
Once you click on
Action on Google,
you will see this dialogue.
That was it.
Congrats!
You could read more details in
the link in the documentation
here.
Thank you for watching
this introduction video.
If you like, we also have
a blog post on this topic.
Also, please make sure to
check out our other episodes.
We love your feedback, so
please don't be a stranger,
and leave us comments.
Until next time, be strong
and create amazing actions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]